[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es einen fünf minuten bisher
was er gerade jetzt zur ramadan seit
perfekt zubereiten könnt aber auch
außerhalb der ramadan zeit ist es
wirklich das perfekte des m und zwar
heißt es katar + partners den im prinzip
so einzelne schichten wie so eine art
blätterteig aber in der türkei wird
nicht blätterteig gemacht sondern
einfach super verwendet entweder ein
wackler bei uns schon ganz dünner
strudelteig ich nehme jetzt aber gleich
viel oder ihr braucht dafür wirklich nur
fünf zutaten und das ist ein bisher was
ich auch aus der türkei kenne man kennt
zum einen aus gaziantep wir haben es
aber auch schon im magath oder in
istanbul gegessen und zwar gibt es da so
eine kette die nennt sich marco und die
machen wirklich gute desserts auch franz
guter hauptspeisen und das ist ein
bisher gefüllt mit pistazien ganz dünn
gebacken
man könnte meinen dass wer herzhaft weil
es einfach wie billig aussieht aber es
ist wirklich richtig lecker das ganze
ist auch nicht so süß so dass ihr euch
jetzt entscheiden können ob ihr noch ein
zuckersirup dazu machen wollt oder nicht
ich zeit mich jetzt gleich noch wie ich
den zuckersirup ansätze ansonsten könnte
es aber auch wirklich komplett ohne
servieren und dann habt ihr wirklich
auch nur die fünf zutaten und in fünf
minuten ist es auch schon fertig aber
wie gesagt mache ich jetzt auch den
zuckersirup denn man bekommt auch dort
immer auf so einem schönen teller
angerichtet und dann den zuckersirup in
einem kleinen kärtchen und man kann
einfach dann selber dosieren wies man es
haben will
für den zuckersirup nämlich 50 gramm
wasser 100 gramm zucker ein bisschen
orangenblüten wasser und etwas
zitronensaft
ich gebe jetzt einfach das wasser
erinnert ob den zucker hinterher
orangenblüten wasser könnt ihr auch
gerne nehmen das macht einfach etwas
orientalisch jetzt gerichtes hier kurz
und lass es dann direkt schon auf dem
herd aufkochen und beim kochen da achte
ich darauf dass es vom löffel herunter
fließt wie so ein faden also darf man
einfach nicht mehr zu flüssig sein aber
auch nicht zu dick wir wollen ja keine
zero persch also in dicken sirup
erstellen und dann gebe ich einfach nur
einen spritzer zitronensaft mit rein
damit das ganze nicht kristallisiert und
geschmacklich passt eben auch dazu aber
wie gesagt müsst ihr das nicht das könnt
ihr nur machen
[Musik]
du bist hier muss es auch also man sieht
jetzt hier das ist der faden immer noch
so ein bisschen abreißt jetzt ist
perfekt jetzt fließt schön geschmeidig
und jetzt einfach nur einen kleinen
spritzer zitronensaft rhein geben und
dann einfach abkühlen lassen
wer das restliche das er braucht ihr
wirklich nur diese fünf zutaten
ich habe jetzt hier viel teig blätterte
bekommt ihr in jedem supermarkt und die
sind einfach richtig schön dünn also
strudelteig blättert dann habe ich hier
etwas crème fraiche normalerweise gehört
aber keiner krank ist einfach rahmen so
ein süßer rahmen ich habe ich noch
pistazien puderzucker und butter das war
schon die große menge butter die kann
ich jetzt schon mal schmelzen die
brauche ich nämlich gleich zum
bestreichen und die kleine menge butter
gebe ich jetzt auch direkt schon in eine
große pfanne
die kann ich hier auch schon mal
schmelzen
dann geht es los dann nehmt ihr euch
jetzt einfach zwei viele blätter
übereinander immer dann schnell arbeiten
damit die einfach nicht austrocknen
ich sehe hier schon das erste ist ein
bisschen trocken
das wird sich dann für was anderes und
dann schon wieder butter bestreichen
als nächstes den rahmen nehmen
[Musik]
mit kai makus halt wirklich original
türkisch den rahm verteile ich jetzt
mehr hier so in der mitte auch die
pistazie sind noch zerkleinern mahlen
[Musik]
ich mal seht so dass ein rascheln
feinden als andere so ein bisschen grob
und vier portionen mache einfach immer
alles schön ich eben auge heißt es im
geistigen auge im geistigen auge
vierteln lasse so könnt ihr euch das
dann immer schön auf teile von der
position her wenn wir sind jetzt auch
für also nehme ich jetzt hier im viertel
dann noch den tod der zucker drüber und
stadt bis tat sehen könnt ihr zum
beispiel auch mandel nehmen oder
walnüssen haselnüssen bleibt euch
überlassen
ok und jetzt einfach schön
zusammenklappen
ich glaube jetzt hier die eine seite ein
wieso eine kleine tasche dann die andere
und einmal von oben nach unten
und dann habt ihr ein kleines päckchen
so bereite ich jetzt kurz alle vor und
dann werden sie schon ausgebacken wie
versprochen fünf zutaten fünf minuten
jetzt ist hier die butter schon schön
geschmolzen und ich kann im prinzip
schon alles auspacken also von beiden
seiten einfach bisher schön goldbraun
ist und dann wird es dass er gleich warm
serviert entweder zu einer kugel eis
joghurt eis passt perfekt oder zu einer
kugel kugel sei schon zu einem löffel
kalten sahnejoghurt also richtig
stichfest und dazu dann noch ein paar
gehackten pistazien noch der zirkus
sirup mehr braucht es die pfanne heiser
ist
guttenberg stellt damit die butter nicht
verbrennt butter bei stufe 1 und die
jetzt bei okay ich habe jetzt auch den
pfannen und sensor drin bei stufe 4
aber ansonsten beim mittel hoher hitze
einfach schön auspacken von beiden
seiten honig david moore ab zum
probieren
ich rechne mir meine teller und den
joghurt und den zuckersirup habe ich
übrigens schon umgefüllt in kleine
kännchen also jetzt eine grosse kammer
seine mutter kann aber ich hier so
bekommt man sie in der türkei dann auch
serviert also richtig schön und dann
kann man sich eben auch die süße
dosieren an so manche nehmen dann das
ganze kännchen andere noch ein bisschen
kann man dann selber variieren
[Musik]
so jetzt habe ich alle fertig angebracht
ich rufe mal überhaupt zum essen orad
orad essen ist fertig einmal die küche
bitte schnell
so zum servieren schneide ich jetzt
zuerst einmal dreiecke wahnsinn das hat
meine mama im mund gemacht ist ja wohl
und zwar hat meine mama dafür nennt sich
das ich kenne das in der türkei im
urlaub zeit und da sind dann die frauen
so einem riesengroßen wie so eine
riesige pfanne ist ja ja so offen und
das dann machen das ist so lecker ja ich
lieb dich echt und das kann man auch mit
kartoffeln machen
niederstadtfeld das ist was mach ich
muss mir das haben wir beim motto wege
ich habe gedacht ich krieg was
herzhaftes doch okay es ist dann mache
ich es nochmal ach das ist ja der
wahnsinn
das habe ich damals in der türkei bei
mario gegessen
marco hört sich an wie mario ist ein
bekanntes restaurant türkei ist eine
kette und die machen halt richtig tolle
sachen ja jetzt ist richtig habe ich
richtig und ich hab setzt hier guck mal
ich hab mein motorrad ist ja das ist
falsch gemacht mit dem kartoffeln
jährlich gemacht so coole sache dann
kannst du ja aber du bist auch nicht
schlecht okay du bist auch gut so
dann probiert es aus also wenn marta
haben wir es einmal mit eis gegessen und
einmal mit joghurt aber ich finde es
tatsächlich mit joghurt besser die
wirkliche stichfesten joghurt nehmen
das hört sich komisch an joghurt mit
etwas süßem obwohl es gibt ja ich glaube
eher dass im deutschen joghurt mit etwas
herzhaftem komisch ist weil die türkei
essen alles mit joghurt und in
deutschland kenne ich ja gott nur bei
müsli als dessert aber die
lebenserwartung die tür quietscht
nämlich auch joghurt und weg zu bekommen
das ist normal in deutschland ist
joghurt sie so zur kartoffel quark
so oder jahr so gut ihr könnt aber
schreiben so was er gerne yoga wird also
hier noch pakistan sind wie gesagt das
ist jetzt noch nicht so süß aber jetzt
nehmt ihr das
und dieses canceln und gibt es jetzt
hier schon drüber
[Musik]
erst wieder nichts sagen aber wem ich
jetzt das wasser im mund zusammenläuft
weil du kannst mal angefangen ich mal er
mit bewundert aber könnte es aber mit
spinat und die verzichtbaren herz ist so
genial da hab ich ja hot summer
ich weiß es sollte gerade euch
wahrscheinlich vielleicht schon jetzt
gefassten dann probier jetzt auf jeden
fall schon mal alle zutaten und das ist
halt jetzt perfekt die kombi denn der
joghurt ist nicht gelöst
das heißt einfach nur stichwörter kalter
naturjoghurt sahne joghurt hier die
leichte süße war aber ich weiß nicht zu
arg süß ich bei orientalischen speisen
oftmals so weil sie so zu benutzen aber
das ist so genial
diese kombi hammer und dann das
orangenblüten wasser und nehmen sie ruft
mega ist natürlich jetzt voll übertragen
wollte könnte folgendes machen anstatt
den joghurt könnt ihr auch vanille eis
zu nehmen
da haben das haben übertrieben nicht was
zitroneneis die drohen heißt aber dann
haben sie übertrieben oder oder
übertreibt nicht eure rolle nimmt
joghurt dazu wirklich also einmal kriegt
die portionen finde ich schon gut
alleine weil es eben nicht so süß ist
wurde ihr sagt ihr teils dann sind es 18
ich weiß aber wenn man vielleicht auch
abendlichen essen will er langsam
wir machen jetzt die kamera aus wenn ich
doch durchschnitt unbedingt probieren
das rezept gibt es zum nachlesen
natürlich kostenlos in meiner app in der
tennis welt app könnte überall kostenlos
herunterladen für im google store oder
auch apple und probiert es einfach aus
fünf minuten fünf zutaten und perfektes
du hast du nicht sag mal selbstsüchtig
ohne spaß einfach mal ist er süchtig
bist aber geschmeckt hat wir müssen
diesmal alles teil räumen im winter
stelle ich mir das noch vor mit
haselnüssen
tonka so richtig so weil weiter redet
kann ich nicht alles ist ich hoffe ihr
habt ihr dann mach ich bereit gleich
noch die nächsten zu und dann essen wir
uns jetzt alle also bis zum nächsten mal
größer meine liebe mama mama gerne
berichten
helga schuchardt spd wäre das von aqua
jogging muss der deckel muss das haben
was sie an mir haben sie denn jetzt
haben sie macht es gut an dem die blog
ja annehmen wie japan jährlich muss ich
ja sagen denn tandem schuldig sind es
dreimal ja mama kocht am besten
[Musik]